time now for the uplift at eight that's
where we share stories that we're
bringing some joy to your day work on
those smile lines jamie you're here what
do you got for i mean i'm working on the
smiles right here today's story is about
a penguin with some very happy feet
thanks to a special new pair of boots
lucas the penguin was given orthopedic
boots made just for him the
four-year-old african penguin has a
chronic condition called yes this is
what it's called bumblefoot which can
cause serious problems for penguins and
made him limp the cushion shoes stay on
with velcro and make walking less
painful now his caregivers at the san
diego zoo say lucas can keep up with
other penguins climb over rocks and the
best part he's not limping anymore
so he can see i'm so excited that we've
been able to do this for lucas lucas was
one of the first birds that i raised
here at san diego zoo so it warms my
heart just to know that we've been able
to do something to make him more
comfortable
and to make him fit into the colony a
little bit better
the zoo keepers say they noticed an
immediate difference with the boots
they're hopeful they will keep lucas
comfortable on his feet i mean it's a
scale right there look at that oh wow
king penguin that's it that's it that
one's going to be asking for its own
boots pretty soon
no cars heels heels heels that's right
that's right it needs some heels but i
mean who doesn't love a penguin when
it's when it when it is like doing what
it's designed for of course it's
beautiful and when it's awkward it's as
awkward as all of us
wonderfully relatable animals we can all
identify i think we'll all end up with
some orthopedic
some similar boots yesterday you're
right about that
oh man good stuff well done jamie thank
you jamie